the
really interesting thing about harvey
weinstein and
you choosing these exceptionally
difficult cases
is also thinking about
what it means to defend evil people
what it means to defend these we could
say unpopular
and you might push back against the word
evil
but bad people in society
first of all do you think there's such a
thing as evil or do you think all people
are good
and it's just circumstances that create
evil
and also is there somebody too evil for
the law to defend
and so that's a so the first question
that's a deep uh philosophical question
whether the category of evil uh does any
work uh for me i it does for me
i i do think that i do subscribe
to that category that there is uh evil
in the world as conventionally uh
understood so
uh so there are many who will say yeah
that just doesn't
doesn't do any work for me uh but the
the category evil in fact does
intellectual work
for me and i i understand it as as
something that
uh that uh exists uh is it genetic or is
it the circumstance like
what kind of work does it do for you
intellectually i think that
it's highly contingent that is to say
that
the conditions in which one
grows up and so forth uh uh
uh begins to create
this category that we may think of as
evil now there
are um studies and and whatnot that show
that uh certain um brain
abnormalities and so forth are more
prevalent in say
serial killer so there may be a
biological
predisposition to certain forms of
conduct but
um i don't uh i don't have
the uh biological evidence to make a
statement that someone is born
evil and and you know i i'm not a
determinist
thinker in that way so you come out the
womb evil and you're destined to be that
way
um to the extent there may be biological
uh determinants uh that still require
some um uh nurture as well
uh so but do you still put a
responsibility
for the on the individual of course yeah
we all make choices
and so some responsibility on the
individual
indeed
we live in a culture unfortunately where
a lot of people
have a constellation of bad choices in
front of them and that makes me very sad
yeah um that the people grow up with
with
predominantly bad choices in in front of
them and that's unfair
and that's that that's on all of us uh
but yes i do think we make we make
choices
wow that's so powerful the constellation
of bad choices
hey
that's such a powerful way to think
about
sort of equality which is
this the set of trajectories before you
that you could take if you just roll the
dice because uh
you know life is is a kind of
optimization problem
sorry to take us into math over a set of
trajectories
under imperfect information uh
so you're gonna do a lot of stupid [ __ ]
to put it
uh in technical terms uh
but uh the
the the fraction of the trajectories
that take you into into bad places
or into good places is really important
and that's ultimately what we're talking
about
and evil might be just a little bit of a
predisposition biologically but the rest
is just trajectories that you can take
you